hey guys it's Jan here as I said in my
review I was seriously impressed with
season 2 of Marvel's daredevil on
Netflix not only other some great new
characters on board this year but it's
also absolutely jam-packed with shocking
heart in your mouth moments so I wanted
to look back over the most WTF moments
in this video just before kicking off
though I've got an awesome giveaway from
our friends at Entertainment Earth for a
chance to win this exclusive pair of
Marvel collectibles that lost Infinity
Gauntlet milk and punishes dog tags make
sure you subscribe and comment about
your favorite moment in season 2 on this
video for more details and ways to enter
the giveaway check out the gleam link in
the video description below and also the
links to the prizes on Entertainment
earth com obviously spoilers ahead if
you haven't watched the whole of season
2 already and if that's you i've got an
on spoiler review for you right here in
the final episode and after battling
ninjas literally getting pulled through
a wall and having a heart-to-heart with
matt electra faces off against a barrage
of katana and longbow wielding ninjas on
the roof with daredevil during the fight
Nobu hits daredevil so hard that he
knocks his mask off and is about to kill
him when he ends up stabbing Elektra
instead as she tries to save daredevil I
know now what it feels to be good
this is not the end she tells Matt and
just so he thought the final episode was
over with Matt's reveal of his daredevil
identity to Karen the camera cuts -
Electress open grave and then we see
Elektra who's dressed in red silk
similar to a comic book costume being
filled in the hand sarcophagus I cannot
wait to see how the hand resurrect her
for next season with a fantastic fight
sequence that makes good use of confined
spaces in episode 12 but the fight isn't
the only reason this sequence earns its
WTF status it all starts with a
beautiful shot of daredevil inching down
into the sewers where he jumps to the
ground and a superhero landing pose
before walking through the tunnel
towards the camera it's not until he
hears a sword swish that he realizes
he's been surrounded by ninjas but he
gets disoriented and can't use his radar
sense when they drop their weapons and
after climbing up a ladder from the
tunnels he flails about when he's
attacked by yet more
Ginger's that is until he hears stick
who's been captured by the hand and held
near by stick tells dirt I gotta track
the ninjas breath and as he does that he
wipes the floor with N in gerace's but
that's not the end of it
daredevil confronts the men torturing
stick who take the bloody peace out of
one of the captors ears then Elektra
arrives to kill stick for trying to have
her killed and no boot ends up with more
ninjas to revealed Elektra is actually
the mysterious black sky in other words
the hands greatest living weapon after
daredevil and punishes rooftop brawl in
Episode one which saw Frank Castle bring
a gun to a foot and fist fight it wasn't
long before the two men were at it again
episode 2 saw the man without fear face
off with castle once more only this time
they had a leaky water tower raining
down on them and a hail of bullets from
police he'd set a trap for castle but
ending that battle chained up after
falling through a glass ceiling was just
the beginning of Daredevils problems yes
after discussing ethics and facing
castles moral conundrum daredevil had to
contend with a horde of angry bikers on
the rampage after castle blew up their
bikes let's just say those chains you've
been tied up in actually came in rather
handy as daredevil brought his way
through one dogs of Hell biker after
another down a long corridor and flights
of stairs kicking punching running up
walls and back flipping his way out of
danger this whole sequence is incredibly
choreographed acted and shot from
Daredevils down and dirty brawling mixed
with martial arts influences to his
Smashing the ceiling lights with his
chains to the red lightnin drenched the
second part of the scene and daredevil
taking a moment to stretch his neck
before starting his second ass-kicking
session
clearly the intention was to up the ante
from the already amazing corridor fight
we saw in season 1 which was an enlarged
to the movie's old boy although Wilson
Fisk wasn't in trailers for season 2 I
had a sneaky suspicion he'd be making a
comeback this year so I was delighted
when he popped up right at the end of
episode 8 to tell new prison inmate
Frank Castle I see you got my message
such a simple line yet so loaded with
meaning about the nature extent of fists
power even when he's incarcerated at
that point he was already running one of
the prison guards and with castles help
he soon became the new prison kingpin in
red wine steak and a flat-screen TV in
his cell
I loved Vincent d'Onofrio's nicely
understated turn as a shadowy Fisk in
season one and he certainly brought the
brilliance again this season making sure
we knew that with Fisk
danger is ever-present no matter how
softly spoken or cultured he appears
during the exchange between fiscal
fellow prisoner Dutton who lays down the
law in episode 9 you just knew Justin
was already living on borrowed time and
what about when Matt Murdock goes to see
Fisk in prison to confront him about
Frank castles escape this goes from
restrained to caged beast in a matter of
minutes
when Murdock's threatens to make sure
Fisk never sees his beloved Vanessa
again Frank Castle didn't realize quite
what he was getting himself into with
Fisk when he agreed to off the prison
big-shot Dutton who facilitated the
Central Park deal between the dogs of
hell Irish mob and Mexican cartel during
which castles family was wiped out after
taking out Justin's right-hand man
Castle puts his ship to use dragging the
truth out of Dustin about what went down
that fateful day including details about
the involvement of undercover cops and
the blacksmith a shadowy new player in
the drug trade but it's what happens
after this that makes this scene a true
WTF moment when Castle tries to exit
Justin's cellblock after killing him the
prison guards on Fisk's payroll won't
let him out
instead they open the cell doors to
Dustin's men so they can kill Castle Q
Castle slashing stabbing stamping and
pummeling his way through a pack of
enraged and armed prisoners until he's
the last man standing and his space arms
and white prison uniform are soaked in
blood it's an especially savage scene
which showcases castles brutal
no-holds-barred fighting style to great
effects and of course it all happens in
a narrow corridor something that's fast
becoming a signature of the show's
action scenes of course there were loads
of other crazy moments this season too
including the Irish mob boss Finn's
stabbing one of his associates in the
eye and torturing Castle the creepy
children being tapped for their blood
the big ninja fight at the hospital the
sequence at the yeah kotomi building and
tons more now at the moment
that shocked you most in season two of
daredevil tell me in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe and leave
a comment about your favorite season 2
moment on this video for a chance to win
this awesome / of exclusive Marvel
collectibles from our friends at
Entertainment earth for more details and
ways to enter the giveaway plus links to
what you can win check out the gleam
link in the video description below and
if you like this video I've got loads
more comic-book movie and TV videos for
both Marvel and DC so check out the
playlist here and do subscribe thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay superhero lovers